قال الماسك اخبار اليوم ناريه في ماسك
خلاص اعلن الحرب على ابل رسميا بعد ما احد
متابعينه وقال انه احتمال ابل وجوجل يحذف
تويتر من متاجرهم وانه ماسك لازم ينتج
هاتف جديد واقطع رد ماسك وقال انه ما
بيتمنى يصير هذا الشيء بس لو صار راح ينتج
هاتف بديل يبدو انه التلميحات صارت واقع
وماسك خلاص اعلن الحرب على ابل اللي
بتسيطر بطبيعه الحال على اختيار التطبيقات
المسموحه في مجرها
بشكل مباشر
التطبيقات وما تم اخباره طبعا متجر
تطبيقات عبر الطريق الوحيد لتوزيع البرامج
على اجهزه ايفون واذا تم واا قبل كمان
يعني واذا تم ازاله تويتر ستفقد الشبكه
الاجتماعيه احدى من الصوت التوزيع
الرئيسيه واشار ماسك انه ابل اوقفت اغلب
اعلانات على تويتر وتسائل انه هل ابل
بيكرهو حريه التعبير في امريكا وارفق هذه
التغريده بالثاني عمل فيها منشن للرئيس
التنفيذي للابل تم كوك وسالوه ايش اللي
جالس بيصير هنا ومو بس كده ماسك نزل في
سيل من التغريدات هجوم في ابل ونقض
واستفسارات فقال مثلا انها بتحضريبه سريه
30% سنويا على كل شيء بتشتروا من اب ستور
ونشر استطلاع سال فيه الناس انه برايكم هل
ابل لازم تنشر جميع اجراءات الرقابه اللي
اتخذتها واللي بتاثر على العملاءها هناك
كانت النتيجه 85% نعم و15% لا
خذ العينات بس من السلخ اللي سلخ وماسك
كدا مقتطفات يعني يعني حتى لما مغرد كتب
له انه لو في احد قادر يدخل بسرعه مع ابل
وعنده فرصه يكسبها فهو الماسك لكنه بحاجه
لحلفاء ماسك رد على التغريده وقال له انه
اي دعم محل تقدير امامكم هذه الانتقادات
والتغريدات شركه ابل ملتزم الصمت وما ردت
ابدا على اي شيء ولا حتى تعلقت لكن
التداول معلومات انه في الشلل اللي هو
بيشرف على مراجعه التطبيقات في ابل حذف
حساب من تويتر في وقت سابق من هذا الشهر
بعد ما تولع ماسك منصبه تمام ينضم الينا
عبر الزوم المحرر التقني في عند الفنان
العربيه عبد الله السبع اهلا فيك معنا عبد
الله يعني الحرب على الماسك جالسه شغاله
من نواحي كثيره يبدو انه ابل الان احدث
المنضمين ليش يوقفوا اعلانات
اول شيء يعطيكم العافيه على هذه الاستضافه
لازم نعرف معلومه ان خلاف لهم ماسك مع ابل
تراب مو بس هذه الفتره تراي لهم ماسك
عندها مشاكل في السنوات الماضيه وكانت
عندها مشاكل مختلفه مع ابل يعني قبل فتره
كانت تسلا تعاني من مشاكل وممكن تدخل في
مرحله الفلاش وحاول يعرض الشركه على الابل
والاسف ما تمت البيعه من بعدها الى الناس
كان عنده تحفظ كبير على هذه الشركه يعني
بعطيكم معلومه مثلا سيارات تسلا حتى الان
ما تدعم نظام ابل السيارات وفي قيود معينه
كده يعني
اصلا القلوب مليانه القلوب مليانه
والخلافات ما بينهم ترى ابدا يعني ما هي
على قولتهم بسيطه لكن انا اختلف معي لهم
ماسك يوم قال ضريبه سريه على التطبيقات
هذه الضريبه او ايضا ابل تاخذ حصتها من
متاجر من التطبيقات اللي بتكون موجوده في
متاجر التطبيقات وشقق للمعلوميه صارت ما
حد شركات الالعاب المشهوره اللي كانت
موجوده على منصه ابل رفضت تدفع 30% وابل
على طول اقساطها الماده التطبيقات ولا
صارت موجوده وهذه الشركه حاليا تعاني من
مشاكل مختلفه بسبب استبعادها متجر ابل
للاسف خسرت عدد كبير من المستخدمين
والتجاره والمستخدمين الى الالعاب بديله
همم
واضح انه يعني بده يحارب على اي دولار
عشان يزيد اربعه واضح ان الموضوع عنده مهم
جدا لهذه الدرجه طيب غير هذه الخناقه يكون
ابل انه توقف اعلاناتها هذا موقف سياسي
نوعا ما او هذا موقف يعبر عن عدم ايمانه
في ال المصري
لكن لازم نعرف معلومه ترى مو بس افضل وقفت
الاعلانات كثيره في السوق الامريكي وقفت
اعلانات في تويتر
من اسلوب ال الماسك عبروا عن عدم رضاهم من
انه يقول حريه التعبير
مختلفه موجوده بالسوق
عندها تحفظ على الدعايه بعد استحواذ لهم
ماسك على تويتر فلذلك الموضوع ترى بسيط
جدا وما هو متعلق في الدعاياته ومتعلق في
نسبه ال 30 انا اشوف وهو رئيس شخص يحتمل
الصواب ويحتمل الخطا وهو ان من حق اضل اخذ
30% تخيل انك انت تروح الى مول مشهور
معروف كل الزوار
وتتاخد محل داخل هذا المول لكن رافض انك
تدفع ايجار داخل هذا الموت هذا اللي صاير
الان في متجر التطبيقات واحد من اكثر
المتاجر اه في عالم التطبيقات واحد من
اكثر المتاجر ربحا في عالم متاجر
التطبيقات فاذا حطيت تطبيقك في حقل الشركه
لا تاخذ 30% لانها توفر بلاتور معينه انها
توفر نظام دفع معين يعطيك معلومه ومعلومه
هذه معروفه وممكن نختلف فيها قبل تقطعيني
انه الان نفس التطبيق اللي موجود على
تطبيقات او متجر ابل ونفس التطبيق موجود
على متجر اندرويد ارباح من التطبيق على
ابل اعلى بكثير من ارباحها على الاندرويد
لانه مستخدمين افضل يدفعون عكس مستخدمين
الاندرويد على مصادر مجانيه وممكن يركبونه
بطريقه قانونيه لتوفير الدفع فلذلك
تطبيقات حلوه كثيره وارباح مختلفه طائله
جدا
لاسباب اخرى غير اللي جالس هو يعلنها
صراحه يعني
هو قيل فات موجوده ما بيني وبين ابل ولازم
نعرف ان ماهي اول مره
راحت وعملت الخطوه هذه يا سيدي قال لهم
طيب اوكي حلينا مشكله ال 30% خده 30% حقكم
عادي
واذا راحوا استمروا وشالوا التطبيق من
المتجر ما تعتقد انه رده الفعل حتكون
كبيره جدا من الناس خصوصا تطبيق بحجم
تويتر واستخداماته سواء الاخباريه من
السياسيين وما الا ذلك
فيها واستخدمها لكن ما اتوقع يوصل الموضوع
الى حذف التطبيق من متجر التطبيقات لانه
لا حساسيه كبيره وقبل اساسا تعتمد عليها
يعني
اساسا يعتمد على تويتر
لمؤتمرات ابل وغيرها من المؤتمراته فلذلك
اتوقع لن يصل الموضوع الى الحذف لكن اني
انا اولوح في وسيله قد اضغط عليك حتى ترضخ
لقوانين الخاصه فيني ولا تسبب لي ازعاج
هذا اللي يتوقع الاصاله
السير تويتر منصه للتلويح والتهديد لكل
الاطراف عشان تفهم الرساله قبل ما يصير
المشكله طيب نحنا بنشكرك على هذه المداخله
كان معنا عبر الزوم المحرر التقني في اند
فندم العربيه عبد الله السبع شكرا لك عبد
الله
[موسيقى]